[Music]
mr speaker
the president of the united states
so
do
members of the congress
i have the great pleasure
the high privilege
and a distinct
and personal honor
of presenting to you
the president of the united states
[Applause]
thank you
very much
mr speaker
mr president
my colleagues in the congress
our distinguished guests and my fellow
americans
to address the joint session of the
congress in this great chamber in which
i was once privileged to serve
is an honor for which i am deeply
grateful
the state of the union addresses
traditionally an occasion for a lengthy
and detailed account by the president of
what he has accomplished
in the past
what he wants the congress to do in the
future
and in an election year to lay the basis
for the political issues which might be
decisive in the fall
occasionally there comes a time
when profound and far-reaching events
command
a break with tradition
this is such a time
i say this not only because 1970 marks
the beginning of a new decade in which
america will celebrate its 200th
birthday
i say it because new knowledge and hard
experience
argue persuasively
that both our programs and our
institutions in america need to be
reformed
the moment has arrived to harness the
vast energies
and abundance of this land
to the creation of a new american
experience
and experience richer and deeper and
more truly a reflection of the goodness
and grace
of the human spirit
the seventies will be a time of new
beginnings
a time of exploring both on the earth
and in the heavens
a time of discovery
but the time has also come for emphasis
on developing better ways
of managing what we have
and of completing what man's genius has
begun
but left unfinished
our land
this land that is ours together is a
great
and a good land it is also an unfinished
land
and the challenge of perfecting it is
the summons of the seventies
it is in that spirit that i address
myself to those great issues facing our
nation
which are above partisanship
when we speak of america's priorities
the first priority must always be
peace for america and the world
the major immediate goal of our foreign
policy is to bring an end to the war in
vietnam in a way
that our generation will be remembered
not so much as the generation that
suffered in war
but more for the fact
that we had the courage and character to
win the kind of a just peace that the
next generation was able to keep
we are making progress toward that goal
the prospects for peace are far greater
today than they were a year ago
a major part of the credit for this
development
goes to the members of this congress
who despite their differences on the
conduct of the war
have overwhelmingly indicated their
support of a just peace
by this action
you have completely demolished the
enemy's hopes
that they can gain in washington the
victory our fighting men have denied
them in vietnam
[Applause]
no goal could be greater than to make
the next generation the first in this
century in which america was at peace
with every nation in the world
i shall discuss and detail the new
concepts and programs designed to
achieve this goal in a separate report
on foreign policy which i shall submit
to the congress at a later date
today let me describe the directions of
our new policies
we have based our policies on an
evaluation of the world as it is
not as it was 25 years ago at the
conclusion of world war ii
many of the policies which were
necessary and right then are obsolete
today
then because of america's overwhelming
military and economic strength
because of the weakness of other major
free world powers
and the inability of scores of newly
independent nations to defend
or
even govern themselves
america had to assume the major burden
for the defense of freedom in the world
in two wars first in korea
and now in vietnam we furnish most of
the money most of the arms most of the
men
to help other nations defend their
freedom
today
the great industrial nations of europe
as well as japan
have regained their economic strength
and the nations of latin america and
many of the nations who acquired their
freedom from colonialism after world war
ii in asia and africa
have a new sense of pride and dignity
and a determination to assume the
responsibility
for their own defense
that is the basis of the doctrine i
announced it juan
neither the defense nor the development
of other nations can be exclusively or
primarily an american undertaking
the nations of each part of the world
should assume the primary responsibility
for their own well-being
and they themselves should determine the
terms of that well-being
we shall be faithful to our treaty
commitments
but we shall reduce our involvement and
our presence in other nations affairs
to insist
to insist that other nations play a role
is not a retreat from responsibility
it is a sharing of responsibility
the result of this new policy
has been not to weaken our alliances but
to give them new life new strength a new
sense of common purpose
relations with our european allies are
once again strong and healthy based on
mutual consultation and mutual
responsibility we have initiated a new
approach to latin america in which we
deal
with those nations as partners rather
than patrons
the new partnership concept has been
welcomed in asia
we have developed an historic new basis
for japanese american friendship and
cooperation
which is the linchpin for peace in the
pacific
and if we are to have peace in the last
third of the century a major factor will
be the development of a new relationship
between the united states
and the soviet union
i would not underestimate our
differences
but we are moving with precision and
purpose from an era of confrontation to
an era of negotiation
our negotiations on strategic arms
limitations and in other areas
will have far greater chance for success
if both sides enter them motivated by
mutual self-interest rather than naive
sentimentality
it is with this
[Applause]
this is the same spirit with which we
have resumed discussions with communist
china
in our talks at warsaw
our concern in our relations with both
these nations
is to avoid a catastrophic collision and
to build a solid basis for peaceful
settlement
of our differences
i would be the last to suggest that the
road to peace is not difficult and
dangerous
but i believe our new policies have
contributed to the prospect
that america may have
the best chance since world war ii
to enjoy a generation of uninterrupted
peace
and that chance
will be enormously increased
if we continue to have a relationship
between congress and the executive
in which despite differences in detail
where the security of america
and the peace of mankind are concerned
we act not as republicans not as
democrats but as americans
as we move into the decade of the 70s we
have the greatest opportunity for
progress at home of any people in world
history
our gross national product
will increase by 500 billion dollars in
the next 10 years
this increase alone
is greater than the entire growth of the
american economy from 1790 to 1950.
the critical question is not whether we
will grow but how we will use that
growth
the decade of the 70 of the 60s
was also a period of great growth
economically
but in that same 10-year period
we witnessed the greatest growth of
crime
the greatest increase in inflation the
greatest social unrest in america in a
hundred years
never has a nation seemed to have had
more
and enjoyed it less at heart the issue
is the effectiveness of government
ours has become
as it continues to be and should remain
a society
of large expectations
governments helped to generate those
expectations it undertook to meet them
yet increasingly it proved unable to do
so
as a people
we had too many visions
and too little vision
now
as we enter the 70s we should enter also
a great age of reform of the
institutions of american government
our purpose in this period should not be
simply better management of the programs
of the past
the time has come for a new quest
a quest not for a greater quantity of
what we have
but for a new quality of life in america
a major part of the substance for an
unprecedented advance in this nation's
approach to its problems and
opportunities is contained
in more than two score legislative
proposals which i sent to congress last
year
and which still await enactment
i will offer at least a dozen more major
programs in the course of this session
at this point i do not intend to go
through a detailed listing of what i
have proposed or will propose
but i would like to mention
three areas in which urgent priorities
demand that we move and move now first
we cannot delay longer in accomplishing
a total reform of our welfare system
when a system penalizes work breaks up
homes
robs recipients of dignity there is no
alternative to abolishing that system
and adopting in its place the program of
income support
job training and work incentives which i
recommended to the congress last year
second the time has come to assess and
reform all of our institutions of
government at the federal state and
local level it is time for a new
federalism
in which after 190 years of power
flowing from the people and local and
state governments to washington dc
it will begin to flow from washington
back to the states and to the people of
the united states
third
we must adopt reforms which will expand
the range of opportunities
for all americans
we can fulfill the american dream only
when each person
has a fair chance
to fulfill his own dreams this means
equal voting rights equal employment
opportunity and new opportunities for
expanded ownership
because in order to be secure in their
human rights
people need access to property rights
i could give similar examples of the
need for reform in our programs for
health education housing transportation
as well as other critical areas which
directly affect the well-being of
millions of americans
the people of the united states should
wait no longer for these reforms
that would so deeply enhance the quality
of their life
when i speak of actions which would be
beneficial to the american people
i can think of none more important than
for the congress to join this
administration
in the battle to stop the rise in the
cost of living
now i realize it is tempting to blame
someone else for inflation
some blame business for raising prices
and some blame unions for asking for
more wages
but a review of the stark fiscal facts
of the 1960s clearly demonstrates where
the primary blame for rising prices must
be placed
in the decade of the 60s the federal
government spent
57 billion dollars more than it took in
in taxes
in that same decade the american people
paid the bill for that deficit
in price increases which raised the cost
of living for the average family of four
by two hundred dollars per month in
america
now millions of americans are forced to
go into debt today
because the federal government decided
to go into debt yesterday
we must balance our federal budget so
that american families will have a
better chance to balance their family
only with the cooperation of the
congress can we meet this highest
priority
authority objective of responsible
government we're on the right track we
had a balanced budget in 1969
this administration cut more than seven
billion dollars out of spending plans in
order to produce a surplus in 1970
and in spite of the fact that congress
reduced revenues by three billion
dollars i shall recommend a balanced
budget for 1971.
but i can assure you that not only to
present but to stay within a balanced
budget requires some very hard decisions
it means rejecting spending programs
which would benefit some of the people
when their net effect would result in
price increases for all the people
it is time to quitting it is time to
quit
putting good money into bad programs
otherwise we will end up with bad money
and bad programs
i recognize the political popularity of
spending programs and particularly in an
election year
but unless we stop the rise in prices
the cost of living for millions of
american families will become unbearable
and government's ability
to plan programs for progress for the
future will become impossible
in referring to budget cuts there is one
area where i have ordered an increase
rather than a cut
and that is the request of those
agencies with the responsibilities for
law enforcement
we've heard a great deal of overblown
rhetoric
we've heard a great deal of overblown
rhetoric during the 60s in which the
word war has perhaps too often been used
the war on poverty the war on misery the
war on disease the war on hunger
but if there is one area where the word
war is appropriate it is in the fight
against crime
we must declare and win the war against
the criminal elements which increasingly
threaten our cities our homes and our
lives
we have a tragic example of this problem
in the nation's capital
for whose safety
the congress and the executive have the
primary responsibility
i doubt
if many members of this congress
who live more than a few blocks from
here
would dare
leave their cars in the capitol garage
and walk home alone tonight
this year this administration sent to
the congress thirteen separate pieces of
legislation dealing with organized crime
pornography street crime narcotics crime
in the district of columbia none of
these bills have reached my desk for
signatures
i am confident that the congress will
act now to adopt the legislation i
placed before you last year
we in the executive have done everything
we can under existing law
but new and stronger weapons are needed
in that fight
while it is true that state and local
law enforcement agencies are the cutting
edge in the effort to eliminate street
crime burglaries murder
my proposals to you have embodied my
belief that the federal government
should play a greater role in working in
partnership
with these agencies
that is why 1971
federal spending for local law
enforcement will double that budgeted
for 1970.
the primary responsibility for crimes
that affect individually individuals
is with local
and state rather than with federal
government
but in the field of organized crime
narcotics pornography the federal
government has a special responsibility
it should fulfill
and we should make washington d.c
where we have the primary responsibility
an example to the nation and the world
of respect for law rather than
lawlessness
i now turn to a subject
which next to our desire for peace may
well become
the major concern
of the american people
in the decade of the seventies
in the next 10 years
we shall increase our wealth by 50
percent
the profound question is
does this mean we will be 50 richer
in a real sense
50
better off
50 happier
or does it mean that in the year 1980
the president
standing in this place
will look back on a decade
in which 70 percent of our people
lived in metropolitan areas choked by
traffic suffocated by smog poisoned by
water deafened by noise and terrorized
by crime
these are not the great questions that
concern world leaders at summit
conferences
but people do not live at the summit
they live in the foothills of everyday
experience
and it is time for all of us to concern
ourselves with the way
real people live
in real
life the great question of the 70s is
shall we surrender to our surroundings
or shall we make our peace with nature
and begin to make reparations for the
damage we have done to our heir to our
land and to our
water restoring nature to its natural
state is a cause beyond party and beyond
factions
it has become a common cause of all the
people of this country
it is a cause of particular concern to
young americans
because they more than we
will reap the grim consequences of our
failure to act on programs which are
needed now if we are to prevent disaster
later
clean air
clean water open spaces
these should once again be the
birthright of every american
if we act now they can be
we still think of air as free
but clean air is not free
and neither is clean water
the price tag and pollution control is
high
through our years of past carelessness
we incurred a debt to nature and now
that debt is being called
program i shall propose to congress will
be the most comprehensive and costly
program
in this field in america's history
it is not a program for just one year a
year's plan in this field is no plan at
all
this is the time to look ahead not a
year
but five years or ten years whatever
time is required to do the job
i shall propose to this congress a 10
billion dollar nationwide clean waters
program
to put modern municipal waste treatment
plants in every place in america where
they are needed to make our waters clean
again and do it now
we have
the industrial capacity if we begin now
to build them all within five years
this program will get them built within
five years
as our cities and suburbs relentlessly
expand
those priceless open spaces needed for
recreation areas accessible to their
people are swallowed up often forever
unless we preserve these spaces while
they are still available
we will have none to preserve
therefore
i shall propose new financing methods
for purchasing open space and park lands
now before they are lost to us
the automobile is our worst polluter of
the air
adequate control requires further
advances in engine design and fuel
composition
we shall intensify our research set
increasingly strict standards and
strengthen enforcement procedures and we
shall do it now
we can no longer afford to consider
air and water
common property
free to be abused by anyone without
regard to the consequences
instead we should begin now to treat
them as scarce resources
which we are no more free to contaminate
than we are free to throw garbage into
our neighbor's yard
this requires comprehensive new
regulations it also requires
that to the extent possible the price of
goods
should be made to include the costs of
producing and disposing of them without
damage to the environment
[Applause]
now i realize that the argument is often
made that
there's a fundamental contradiction
between economic growth and the quality
of life so that to have one
we must forsake the other
the answer is
not to abandon growth but to read but to
redirect it
for example
we should turn toward ending congestion
and eliminating smog the same reservoir
of invented genius that created them in
the first place
continued vigorous economic growth
provides us with the means to enrich
life itself
and to enhance our planet as a place
hospitable to man
each individual
must enlist in this fight if it is to be
won
it has been said that no matter how many
national parks and historical monuments
we buy and develop
the truly significant environment for
each of us
is that in which we spend 80 percent of
our time in our homes
in our places of work the streets over
which we travel
street letter run down parking strips
and yards dilapidated fences broken
windows smoking automobiles dingy
working places
all should be the object
of our fresh view
we have been too tolerant of our
surroundings and too willing to leave it
to others to clean up our environment
it is time for those
who make massive demands on society to
make some minimal demands on themselves
[Applause]
each of us must resolve
that each day
he will leave his home
his property
the public places of the city or town a
little cleaner
a little better a little more pleasant
for himself and those around him
with the help of people we can do
anything
and without their help we can do nothing
in this spirit together
we can reclaim our land for hours and
generations to come
between now and the year 2000
over 100 million children will be born
in the united states
where they grow up and how
will more than any one thing measure the
quality of american life
in these years ahead
this should be a warning to us
for the past 30 years our population has
also been growing and shifting
the result is exemplified in the vast
areas of rural america
emptying out of people and of promise
200 years ago
this was a new nation
of 3 million people
weak militarily
poor economic
but america meant something to the world
then
which could not be measured in dollars
something far more important
than military mining
listen to president thomas jefferson in
1802
we act not for ourselves alone
but for the whole human race
we had a spiritual quality then which
caught the imagination of millions of
people in the world
today
when we are the richest and strongest
nation in the world let it not be
recorded
that we lack the moral and spiritual
idealism which made us the hope of the
world at the time of our birth
the demands of us in 1976 were even
greater than 1776.
it's no longer enough to live and
let live
now we must live and help live
we need a fresh climate in america
one in which a person can breathe freely
and breathe in freedom
our recognition of the truth that wealth
and happiness
are not the same thing requires us
to measure success or failure by new
criteria
even more than the program
i have described today
what this nation needs
is an example from its elected leaders
in providing the spiritual and moral
leadership which no programs for
material progress can satisfy
above all
let us inspire young americans with a
sense of excitement
a sense of destiny
a sense of involvement in meeting the
challenges we face in this great period
of our history
only then are they going to have any
sense of satisfaction in their lives
the greatest privilege an individual can
have
is to serve in a cause
bigger than himself
we have such a cause
how we seize the opportunities i have
described today
will determine not only our future
but the future of peace and freedom in
this world in the last third of the
century
may god give us the wisdom the strength
and above all the idealism
to be worthy of that child
so that america can fulfill its destiny
of being the world's best hope for
liberty
for opportunity
for progress and peace
for all people
[Applause]
[Laughter]
yes
[Applause]
you're watching american history tv
every weekend on c-span 3 explore our
nation's past